let's do this
when they asked me to do stunts for the
lego ninjago movie I thought I had to
use Lego and then I realized oh I can do
a stunt like a live-action martial art
movie that makes more sense in the movie
I play Master Wu so I'm the teacher of
my stunt team and the Ninjago team
I'm very proud of the Jackie Cheston
team they are the best of the best so
the students in India go should be the
best maybe we never work on a movie like
this before it was interesting to make
real-life action into animation my
favorite fight of the movie is between
me and Garmadon is a very important
moment I want that action design to be
very special
now I'm gonna fight you
[Music]
everything the stunting does the ninjas
do awesome there go stinking these are
confirmation I have been doing a stunt
more than fifty years I've never done
anything like this before
trust me this ninjas can really fight
I think you would be very impressive
[Music]
you ready Femina continent jackal Oh
I'll be waiting
dad sorry what was that last thing you
said wait that last part I didn't catch
it well is anything what you mean I
didn't well I said I'll be waiting and
then I stopped talking dad
no Lloyd that's right your son and it's
Lloyd no ll o yd I named you you've
ruined my life
that's not true I haven't even been a
part of your life how could I ruin it
wasn't even there baby now we got bad
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm kicking the Salamis to form the
secret ninja force are you ready to risk
your life Ninjago yes I am
maybe I know you want me to save myself
so
[Music]
hello who is this
Lloyd Garmadon your son
[Music]
it's okay Lloyd nobody's parents are
perfect I mean my mom is weird
and collect seashells your dad levels
cities and attacks innocent people so
they've all got that quarks you know
[Music]